Do you ever approach a tray of chocolate chip cookies,
only to have the soul crushing realization that
they're actually ~oatmeal raisin~?
SOUL CRUSHING!
Yeah...that has nothing to do with today's video,
but honestly this happens way too often to me,
so oatmeal raisin just needs to not exist anymore
if you like oatmeal raisin, I have to question your integrity as a human being.
I QUESTION YOUR INTEGRITY AS A HUMAN BEING!
But, yeah ... anyway, I overanalyze things A LOT.
Mostly really stupid things.
So, I know the frequency of his texting has decreased,
but not necessarily the consistency in which he initiates conversation
and he has an 80% initiation rate
but only 20% of the time he actually address a previous message that I've sent
What about the content of the messages?
Has that experienced a shift?
Energetically, it's at an all time low
What about pic to text ratio?
Pretty high, all things considered, but that could totally be an occupational side effect
[together]: Selfies?
Galore.
[together]: Wow, okay...
[talking over each other] I'll go ahead and make the spreadsheet.
In my time, as an overanalyzer, [ba dum bum]
There's a few recurring themes.
so how do you know if you're one?
1. Instead of living in the moment, and feeling with your intuition and enjoying what is...
you're very preoccupied with either analyzing your past history and mistakes
and how to possibly decipher helpful solutions
which also illicit strict embarrassment/punishment feelings
or you're consulting the unknown future for all the potential scenarios
of how these timelines could play out and what your reactions would be
in those said timelines
Complex, rhetorical scenes are turned over and over in your mind
no matter what you're doing,
and you've convinced yourself that though this is not reality
these illusions are actually helpful preparation for all the possible realities that you may come across
Confused?
YOU'RE NOT BECAUSE YOU'RE AN OVERANALYZER,
AND YOU KNOW EXACTLY WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT
AND I HOPE YOU FEEL PERSONALLY ATTACKED.
2. You play out the worst case scenario fantasies
in your head. On a loop.
This is an extension of 1.
Instead of really indulging in the positive scenarios from these limitless timeline
thereby sort of creating some kind of like, manifestation, or create a visualization
you dwell on all the worst stuff.
because of course, that would happen to you.
and when it does, damn it, you are going to be prepared!
Emotionally, Mentally, Physically! Bring it on!
I'm ready for everyone and anyone to die at any moment and I have a spare change of underwear in my trunk
and you know why.
3. You observe everything, except what's actually happening.
[dramatic music]
What do you think Anna?
Anna : Huh?
4. You take little things very seriously.
You're 2 months old now.
You have to start thinking about your future.
Look, I'm sorry, but if you don't keep up your social media profiles, how is anyone supposed to know to adopt you?
Do you want to stay at santa dora for the rest of your life?
Look, look at your Instagram.
...it's pathetic.
I wouldn't want to adopt you based off of this.
You really need to start thinking in terms of aesthetics.
And finally, we've got the pink links. You know what I'm talking about...
You do a google search, and EVERY link on the first 3 pages is pink
because, GUESS WHAT?
[over dramatic music] You've already done the search 1000 times!
Overanalyzing things is not helpful, and I'm speaking from experience.
It is basically unnecessary worry.
If you're chronically obsessing, overthinking, or overanalyzing
it usually stems from you trying to resolve uncertainty about the future.
And I get it!
I am very uncomfortable with uncertainty.
It is the worst.
Who wants to be in a constant state of  unknown about everything?
But unfortunately, that's just the baseline of reality.
I mean, there's just so much out of your control, and so much that we can't be certain about.
Changing your relationship to uncertainty is the only way to stop constantly seeking answers
for a question that only time has.
Allow yourself to feel uncertain
Stop researching, stop harassing your friends and family, and allow uncertainty.
In fact, maybe try to embrace it.
And I know, it's easier said than done, but trust me it's like a rollercoaster of acceptance
that I've ridden and am currently on the ride for constantly
But the only person who really loses out when you overanalyze, is you.
You lose both time and energy.
so reign it in!
I'm Anna Akana, stay right here for a sponsored message from honey.
With honey, you don't have to worry about hunting down all the best deals.
Because honey is a free browser extension, that automatically finds the best coupons on the web.
So you always get the best prices on everything you buy online.
It works on thousands of websites.
I use in on Amazon and Sephora.
You can go to joinhoney.com/annaakana
and add honey to your browser today
It is completely free, just takes 2 clicks to install, and will save you a ton of money while shopping online.
If you're like me, and you do most of your shopping online,
cause you don't like to leave the house...
There's no reason not to.
Click the link below to add honey to your browser for free,
or, go to joinhoney.com/annaakana
That's, joinhoney.com/annaakana